The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT Open OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BUS LEONARD: All right,
thanks, everybody for coming,
my name is Bus Leonard.
CARTER: I'm Carter.
BRIANNA: I'm Brianna.
BUS LEONARD: And Rosser
is not here right now.
And our team lead is Ken.
And we're working on OJ sealer
for a community in Nicaragua.
We were partnered with
the NGO AsoFenix, which
is a organization that does a
rural sustainable development
projects with multiple
communities in Nicaragua.
And they do projects
that promote
clean water, electricity,
income generation, also
educational projects that
help the community be healthy.
So our project centers around
the community El Roblar
that we visited while
we were down there.
And they have a large orange
harvest crop that they get.
And there's no market for the
oranges during the harvest
season, because everybody's
harvesting oranges.
So the idea is to
create a way for them
to sell the oranges or a
product from the oranges
in the offseason
to generate income.
And they were introduced
a pasteurization process
to preserve the orange
juice by AsoFenix
and through the
University of Managua.
So that process is in place.
And we are trying to
develop a way for them
to seal a plastic bag in
order to preserve the juice.
And this is actually
stemming off
of a project that was started
during last year's D-Lab Energy
class.
And you see that project
picture at the bottom here.
And our specifications
that we want
to achieve with our
project is to have it--
the device be able to run
off 120 volts of AC current
and while-- and
the seal should be
done while removing
the air from the bag.
So there's no air in the bag to
prevent spoiling of the juice
after it's sealed,
before it's sold.
And we also want to
create and maintain
the durable, user friendly
interface that was--
beginning last year with
last year's project.
BRIANNA: So this is a bigger
picture of last year's project.
And it sealed bags
nicely and all,
but there's several
areas that we
feel need improving on before
it can actually really be used.
The first one is
the power supply.
Between last year and this year,
the community we're working in
got rid of all their 12
volt batteries like that
because they got a
micro hydro grid.
And so now they're
running on 120 AC.
So we need to make it actually
be able to run on the power
that they have.
We mentioned removing all
the air from the bags.
The preservation process
isn't very strong.
So it's a key part of making
sure the orange juice stays
good.
The wide flat surface that
they're sealing on here
makes it very, very
difficult to do that.
So we wanted to
improve that as well.
And then when we talk
about comfort in using it,
the light that indicated
whether something is hot or not
was right about here.
And when you would use
it from the other side,
it was very difficult to see.
There's a latch that's
really difficult to open.
And trying to get the bags
to get all the air out,
because of the
wide flat surface,
was also very difficult.
And the control-- the
timing circuit there,
the used an out of the
box timing circuit.
Mainly, I think, because of
limited time that cost $26.
So we're also designing a
simplified timing circuit
built out of just components
that is only going
to be a couple of dollars.
CARTER: So we wanted to
first go into experimentation
and see what needed to be done
to get a good seal on a bag.
So we first started off
with what type of plastic
do we need.
We basically tested-- we got
some plastic from Nicaragua
and we brought it back.
And it turned out to
be 25/1000 of an inch.
So we're testing with 25/1000 of
an inch and 45/1000 of an inch
because there's
various plastics there.
And so we wanted to test with
multiple types of plastic
to accommodate that.
In addition to that, we wanted
to see what temperature was
needed to fully seal plastic.
So we use the standard impulse--
or the industry standard,
which is the impulse
sealer to seal a bag.
And we used a thermocouple
to determine the temperature.
We got a temperature
of about 195 Celsius.
And you can see, gets
a good seal like this.
Let me pass this
around if you want.
The water should be
orange juice, but--
yeah, so we got 195 Celsius.
That's the temperature
we need to hit.
And in addition to
the temperature,
another factor is
pressure, how much
force do you need to put
down on a nichrome wire
to get a good seal.
So we use a force plate
sensor and pushed down on it.
We got about 56 newtons,
which translates
to about 169 kilopascals
on the nichrome wire.
And you could see
over here with--
if you don't apply
enough pressure,
you get a perforated line,
where there's seals--
there's a lot of gaps
in between the seals.
So this is not a good
seal, because there
wasn't enough pressure,
although the time was perfect.
For this, with a
6 kilogram weight,
you got a good, solid
seal on the bag.
Everything looks good.
Water did not leak.
And that is ideal.
In terms of timing,
we also want to make
sure you apply the right amount
of time, or else it melts,
the plastic will
melt. So what we
did was we had a
standard weights,
we applied it to our rig and
tested with constant voltage,
different timing--
so we ran the device for
a certain amount of time
and then increased it slowly.
So as you can see, as
we increased more time,
this was enough-- this
wasn't enough pressure,
because you see the dimples.
But you can see over time, that
is a very small seal to one
that's melted.
And so with various weights,
and various voltages,
and varying the time,
we got figured out
exactly what we need.
So in terms of
power and voltage,
I'll pass it off to Brianna.
BRIANNA: So before I get into
our different tests of power
voltage, I notice that it says
5 volts, 10 volts, 12 volts,
but we were talking
about 120 volts AC.
This is because we decided that
the best way to run something
off the wall power is actually
just to buy an adapter
and plug it in and
convert it to 12 volts DC.
Running something off the
wall makes it very difficult
to have our timing circuit work.
We'd probably have to
rectify that into DC anyway.
120 volts with our nichrome
is like a 4 ohm resistor.
We'd have to add either more
resistors that would do nothing
for the heating and be
expensive because they'd
have to be big power resistors
or lots more nichrome
wire, which would,
again, be expensive.
If we built our own adapter,
the price came out to just about
the same as what 12 volt 3, 4
amp adapters are selling for.
And it would be more complicated
and harder to replace.
So it turns out that the
best solution to running it
off the wall is just to
buy an adapter running off
the 12 volts anyways.
So we did tests with
power and voltage--
power controlled
by what voltage we
were putting across a
resistor and the time
that we left it on for.
These are just a couple
of samples there.
See at 5 volts, even when we
were doing it for a minute,
we didn't get hot enough
to melt the bag at all.
I know the pictures aren't
really great, but bear with us.
At 10 volts, we had a good
seal in just 20 seconds.
And at 12 volts, by the
time it was 14 seconds,
we were already
sealing it too much.
So this was giving
us a good idea
of our trade-offs between
how much power we're
using, what range of powers
and times we can use.
I think we did get a good
seal at 12 volts at about 8
or 10 seconds.
But didn't really have a--
all visible picture
of that to show you.
CARTER: So that was the
experimentation that we did.
And we wanted to use these
results into our design.
So when we designed
our product, we
wanted to take two things
in the mind, functionality
and usability.
Thing about functionality
is we want the users to be
looking down on the product.
So they can use it on a table.
And they also want
a nice latch system.
So as you can see over here,
we have an angled product.
And since the angle, you can
look down on it, use it easily.
I should be taller.
But yeah, and with
this angled plane,
you can have a bag
hanging down as such.
So that the liquid
will be in the bag
and that you can get a
good airtight seal here.
BUS LEONARD: And
then another bonus
is that the excess juice, we're
sealing through juice in order
to get an airtight seal.
The extra juice, you
can just let run off
after you make the seal.
And you can have a
pot sitting right here
to catch the excess juice.
So that's another-- and there's
springs in this arm that
allow you, once
you have-- once we
have a latch system
that will keep
the same force for every seal.
So you'll know that
you have enough force.
And that given the
time and circuit,
it'll run for the
same amount of time.
So the seals will
all be the same.
And then more on
the latch system.
The springs also
provide some give
that will allow this to
compress a little bit more
than the necessary
force for a seal.
So we can just have
a simple rotating
thing out of sheet
metal, something that's
readily available in Nicaragua.
And then you can slide it
over, like the picture.
And then when you want it
off, you can press down.
Slide it back up,
you're ready to go.
CARTER: We got some future
things that we need to work on.
One thing would be
combining the ergonomics,
the usability of this
product, in addition
to the functionality.
We were doing a sample test on
a-- basically just two pieces
of wood testing,
putting weight on top.
And so we need to add nichrome
wire onto the base of this
to seal bags with this design.
In addition to that, we need
to finalize the circuitry
and design a housing
device for the electronics
that we would be
placing on the side.
In addition to that, once
we have this completed,
basically just get
users to test this,
make sure it's intuitive, easy
to use, and a great product
overall.
We'd like to thank
Ken, Amy, Amit, D-Lab
overall, and our community
partner AsoFenix.
Are there any questions?
AUDIENCE: Right now,
are you testing that
by sealing through water?
CARTER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you
seal through pulp?
BUS LEONARD: That's
a good question.
CARTER: We have
yet to test that.
AUDIENCE: It's probably time
to buy some orange juice.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
I would buy the--
AUDIENCE: The super
extra pulpy version,
throw some sticks
and rocks into it.
PROFESSOR: And at one point,
it would be worth it to test,
like actually squeeze
your own juice,
it's not that hard
to make a bit.
AUDIENCE: How
important is the latch?
Why can't you just hold it?
BUS LEONARD: We wanted
to be able to, I guess,
be easily used by
one person, ideally.
So if they-- we're not
sure that this there
could be cases of
filling like liter bags,
or two liter bags of juice
if they're selling it
to restaurants for kind of like
wholesale, like to restaurants.
This force pressing down might
not be enough to hold the bag.
So they might need to be holding
the bag, pressing a button,
so you want you want to
be able to do one thing
at a time with your free hand.
CARTER: In addition
to that, you also want
to have a consent
force for each seal.
So there can be variable forces
if you push harder or less
than each time.
BRIANNA: I'm going
to say that it's also
might be easy for these guys
to remember how much force.
They can always put
enough force on it.
But when I was
doing some tests, I
wasn't always getting
enough force on there.
And the people who are doing
this are women and girls,
so it's--
even like 9, 10,
12-year-old girls,
being able to latch
it down from having
to hold all the pressure
there all the time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] last year.
BUS LEONARD: No,
this is a new arm.
We left the last year's model
in Nicaragua with AsoFenix.
And it works off
the 12 volt battery.
I'm not sure if it's being
used in another community.
BRIANNA: It's not orange
juice season at the moment.
So exactly, right now,
it's not being used.
I don't know whether
they will take it out
to the community to use it
when it becomes orange--
BUS LEONARD: Last
year's project also
did not have the specification
to remove the air.
So using that while removing
the air is also more difficult.
AUDIENCE: Feedback you have
is based on from the field
or from your own--
BUS LEONARD: From the
field, from our spring
break trip down to
Nicaragua and fact
finding there with in El Roblar.
With, yeah.
AUDIENCE: You have any--
show pictures of that testing?
BUS LEONARD: Yeah,
we have pictures.
No, no, thank you.
AUDIENCE: One thing you
might want to think about
is since you're trying to
create at least notionally
sterile stuff, you
might want to start--
it might be time to start
thinking about segregating
this thing into the stuff
you have to keep clean
in the stuff you don't
have to keep clean.
Because having to reach over
with your sterile hand that's
in all the juice
and all the stuff
you're trying to be
clean, and reach over
and hit the button on
the top of the timer
is going to become a drag
if that button somehow
has to stay clean,
if you can give them
things like foot pedals, and
elbow switches, and stuff.
So that just to think
about the process.
And how you're going to
keep the clean stuff clean
and minimize the amount
of stuff you actually
have to use sterile.
AUDIENCE: I probably
missed it, but what
is the price point [INAUDIBLE].
BRIANNA: There aren't devices
that use low power like this.
I'm not sure what the
price for the impulse is,
but running it off batteries
or the micro hydrogrid,
you can't use that.
It uses more power
than-- there's
a limit to the amount of power
that any device they've run off
the micro hydrogrid that
AsoFenix has installed
is allowed to draw.
BUS LEONARD: So
AsoFenix doesn't allow
the use of irons, or hair
dryers, or hair straighteners,
or anything that's heavy
power intensive like that.
BRIANNA: When we compare what
we have to the design that
was made last year, I think
we're probably about $10
less, which if you
don't include a battery,
I think that makes us around $40
instead of around $50, which--
AUDIENCE: So it's
not [INAUDIBLE]..
BRIANNA: No,
instead of sealing--
or instead of the
commercial ones
that use a large amount of
power for about half a second,
this will use 30 watts
for more like 10 seconds.
BUS LEONARD: So
these are our photos
working in the field in the
house we stayed in El Roblar.
A group of about 8 to 10 of
the women of the town came.
And we gave a demonstration
of how it works.
Scroll through.
So this is-- we
found out that there
were number 12 volt batteries.
So we strung up a bunch
of AA and AAA batteries
just to be able to
do the demonstration.
So that--
BRIANNA: We got like
somewhere between 6
and 10 bags of that
for the batteries.
BUS LEONARD: So
this is the process.
And they actually got to
seal a few bags themselves.
Let me if you have any questions
as we're going through.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any sense
about a minimally acceptable
amount of air?
CARTER: We heard from
the community partners
that they didn't want any air.
So in terms of room for
air, we're not sure.
We don't know.
AUDIENCE: Because
I wonder if there's
a correlation between
the size of that bar
that's hanging off
it and how much air.
Presumably, if you make
a really sharp edge.
CARTER: So ideally, we're
going to have the nichrome wire
as close to the edge
as possible to get
as clean a seal as possible.
Because the more--
the further in it is,
the more overlap there is.
So there's going to be
potentially more air.
It's easier to get a--
clamp like this versus top one.
BUS LEONARD: And that's
actually the last photo.
We tried to run it
off solar as well.
But this is getting away
from the presentation more.
AUDIENCE: So how many bags
did you guys seal over
the course of this semester?
BUS LEONARD: Oh,
including the testing,
where we were just doing--
AUDIENCE: Five gallons
worth of orange juice,
or five gallons worth
of water, and 100 bags.
CARTER: We usually just--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? responses, ?]
or is it just [INAUDIBLE]?
CARTER: Off every now and then.
We've been sealing bags the
size of at least 20 or so.
BUS LEONARD: But that was with
our kind of works like model.
So we haven't
combined the sealer
with this ergonomic
application of it
yet to have something that.
AUDIENCE: Are those bags--
individual bags largely
available in Nicaragua?
Or do you get it on a long tube?
BUS LEONARD: You get
it on a long tube.
And we have about six
feet of that tube here.
AUDIENCE: Have you
thought about how
that would-- how
that could change
the process a little bit?
You could fill the whole
tube with orange juice.
CARTER: Seal, seal,
seal, and then just cut.
BRIANNA: We have a long tube.
And that's for the
individual size.
We aren't sure that
that would always
be what they would get,
especially if they're
like one or two liter bags.
So we wanted something--
I think we were trying to go
a little more flexible, rather
than specifically for--
that would only be advantaged
with the long tube.
AUDIENCE: Still use that
process [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Right, and if you
had a little extra add-on
to support [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: That's actually
something [INAUDIBLE]
all you have filled above
what your sealing another half
of bag worth of orange juice.
So you don't have to hold--
If you're filling
one liter bags,
you don't want to have
to hold 50 pounds of bags
above this thing.
But if you have it as
a continuous process,
you've only got like
a 1/2 a bag's worth
of stuff supported above, no
matter what size the bag is.
And then you keep filling it,
once you made that last seal,
then it makes the support
problems a little bit easier.
You might want to start
thinking about that.
AUDIENCE: Does the-- once
the orange juice is sealed,
does it need refrigeration?
As long as there's no air.
BUS LEONARD:
Pasteurization process
that comes before, as
long as there's no air.
Is there a standard for size
of bubble that can remain?
Or does it have to
be absolutely none?
CARTER: We're not sure.
PROFESSOR: You guys were
going to look into that.
Any progress there?
BRIANNA: I think I
think most answer we got
was there needs to be removed.
There needs to be no air.
And whether that's
overstating the requirement
or actually there
really actually
needs to be no air, that's
where we're unsure, I think.
So we're making our goal be
there be actually no air.
PROFESSOR: And you
started testing
to see if you can
actually successfully
seal with zero air, or
zero noticeable air?
BRIANNA: I think we did one with
our flat one that wasn't even
that we had no air in.
AUDIENCE: How crazy is there
pasteurization process?
Put it in a pot, boil
it for 10 minutes,
and then put in the back?
BUS LEONARD: Some citric acid.
AUDIENCE: I'll bet it
depends a lot more on keeping
the clean room clean
than on air in the bag.
Because there's air in the
bottle of Sunny Delight.
There's air at the top of--
there's air at the top
of the jar of pickles.
It's pasteurized.
And it's highly acid.
And you're trying to [INAUDIBLE]
to give them [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Well, it'd be good
to both be able to answer that
and also know even if you have
the answer that air is OK,
if they are convinced
that air is not OK,
that may be a knockout blow.
And so practicing to
make sure the ergonomics
and whatever your
process are set up such
that you can actually ensure
that most of the time,
you're getting a bag with no air
visible I think would be good
to practice that a bunch.
AUDIENCE: I heard you guys talk
about [INAUDIBLE] I'm not sure
if I missed it,
but are you finding
the that keeping [INAUDIBLE]
surface [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm just wondering [INAUDIBLE].
BRIANNA: It probably wouldn't
be directly wood like that.
This was an earlier model.
We've got it covered in
plastic, probably the way
we're going to go.
Last year was
painted or lacquered.
So definitely be some kind of
more wipe-downable surface.
AUDIENCE: As long as it--
what kills wood is going
wet, dry, wet, dry, wet,
dry over and over
again, like if you're
going to run it
all day long wet,
it's not the end of the world.
You just might not want to
make it out of something--
it's nice to be able to
make the surface flat.
So you can clean them.
So really soft [INAUDIBLE]
and harder stuff,
but harder would
repel [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: I think one
of their main concerns
also was capturing
the overflow juice.
In that case, you want
a very sterile surface.
And as clean as you can get.
If you have an extra 8 inches
off your roll of plastic
or 6 inches off
your roll of plastic
that you can just wrap that
bottom portion with it as kind
of runoff.
Then you don't actually have to
worry about cleaning your wood
as much as you would have.
BRIANNA: It's also
nice in the overflow
to soak into the device
rather than being reclaimed.
AUDIENCE: Probably
the first [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: OK, thanks, you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
VIVIAN: Hi, we're
the charcoal group.
I'm Vivian.
JESSICA: I'm Jessica.
CURT: And I'm Curt.
VIVIAN: And our project
mentors are Amelia,
raise your hand, and
Steve over there.
So first, our main--
sorry-- OK, our main
motivation for our project
stems from the work we
did with a Nicaraguan
based NGO called GrupoFenix
and more specifically, we
worked with a cooperative called
the Mujeres Solares, which
is the solar wind.
Basically, we
introduced the idea
of D-Lab's agri-waste charcoal.
And for those of who
aren't familiar with it,
it's basically a process
of making charcoal out
of agri-waste or
biomass, instead of wood.
So you reduce deforestation.
And it burns a lot cleaner.
We really wanted to
improve this process.
So that the women would
feel more comfortable
integrating this into
their everyday lives,
or possibly using this as a
business activity for them.
Right now, there is a general
discomfort with the process.
And Jess can talk to
you a little bit more
about those specifics.
JESSICA: So what was
really unique to our group
was that we had the language
to get the direct feedback
from the women.
So we didn't have to go
through a third person.
Instead, I was able to interpret
exactly what they were saying.
And I have highlighted here
that the biggest issue for them
today is still
covering the barrel,
because they cannot bathe
afterwards after dealing with
so much heat of the barrel.
They say that the heat is
too intensive for them.
And then would bathe
with cold water,
and then they would
get sick afterwards.
So that's the biggest
gap for them right now.
Even when we discussed the
different project ideas
that we had to make the
charcoal process better,
they still brought
us back to we really
want you to work on
the barrel to something
so that it doesn't feel so hot.
VIVIAN: So we're
going to show you
a video of women
doing a charcoal burn.
JESSICA: Well, I
can't fast forward.
This is the third charcoal
burn that the women are
doing by themselves.
We trained them.
And then we had them do the
first two by themselves.
They were successful.
This is the third one.
And you can see that
even in the third trial,
there's still some
uncoordination
in the barrel sealing.
This is a current
design, where the barrel
sits on top of the bricks.
And you have to tilt and kick,
and sometimes kick too much.
And so what we can see here are
the main points, the main pain
points of the
process, which are--
stop that right now, which
are the heat intensity
of the process, which is
what they've identified,
and of course, the safety issue.
And we realize that we
need to address these two
concerns while still meeting
the same quality of a charcoal
burn.
CURT: Great, so in order to meet
these criteria that Jess just
highlighted, our
design submerges
the bricks on which the
barrel sits into the ground.
And so basically,
what we've done,
here, I can show you
on our model here.
This is-- one of the
ideas of the charcoal
burn is that it uses
commonly available materials,
like a oil drum.
So I've used a Natty Ice can
here to, in the same spirit.
And so instead of sitting
on top of the ground,
it now sits on bricks that
are submerged into holes.
And so the design
is pretty simple.
There is a dugout whole.
There are six bricks that
line three channels which
allow for airflow.
In this space right here,
the ground and the barrel
form a seal.
So the barrel does not move
once it's been lit on fire.
And we've calculated
the airflow.
So that there is sufficient
airflow through those channels
into the holes that are at
the bottom of the barrel.
So that the-- while it's
burning, there's enough air.
And so to work on sealing
these channels, we have--
we've come up with these
metal plates right here.
So essentially, this
is just sheet metal.
And it has these handles
on top, we call them.
And they can be pushed
in underneath the--
over, rather, the three
channels to seal them.
And just with a
little bit of sand,
it forms a seal around
the whole barrel.
So eliminates the need
for tilting the barrel,
kicking it, kicking out the
bricks, and all of that.
And we experimented
with a number of shapes
here at the top.
So this is semi-circular.
We also have triangular
shapes, and then
various types of
handles, which Jessica
we'll go into in a second.
So an overview of the benefits
of this design compared
to the existing--
the existing portion
of the process
that we're trying to
fit are first that it
minimizes the heat exposure.
Because the flaming barrel
is now in the ground,
and there's no space
for the-- there's
minimized space for
this heat to come out.
The second is that one person
can seal the barrel, rather
than needing two.
And we can show video
of that right now.
Yeah, so this is
the entire process.
And I'll talk through this.
Third is that you can
still light the barrel
through the channels.
And the barrel doesn't move
once it's on fire and flaming.
So as you can see,
all Jessica is
doing here is just pushing the
plates in at a safe distance
and with minimal exposure
to heat basically.
JESSICA: And so
from our experiment,
we were able to conclude what
designs of sheet and handles
were better equipped to
meet our project attributes.
We wanted to be able
to steer the sheet.
And the better design for that
was the semi-circular plate.
In terms of
maneuvering and being
precise about where
the sheet was going,
the lipped handle, which
is this one right here,
allowed for the wood to come
in and kind of fit right there
just enough to be able to
maneuver the sheet into where
we wanted it.
The lifting
potential of the lift
handle allowed us
to kick the sheet up
a little bit if it ever got
stuck right before the brick.
And the three sheets
worked equally
as well to diminish
the heat exposure
and to lessen the time that
it took to seal the barrel.
Now, stepping back for a second,
the sheet metal is only one
of three sealing--
barrel sealing alternatives that
we're considering right now.
The other two are
inserting a break
into the channel of the
dugout and covering the rest
with sand.
And the third is even
simpler than that,
just shoveling in or pouring
in sand into the three holes.
And of course, on the left,
we have different design--
excuse me, specifications
that we want this to meet.
Because it's part of the
process that before was most
heat intensive.
You'll see, there's an
even spread right now
of all the three designs.
For example, the sheet metal
is best in diminishing,
or in lessening the time
that it takes to seal.
But the sand could be
done from farthest away.
You just sort of take the sand
and throw it into the barrel,
throw it in along the side.
But this is due to the
metrics of the attributes.
For example, the
labor intensity,
we consider that it's
easier to seal the hole.
But you do have to
spend some time finding
the sheet metal, which is
readily available in Nicaragua.
But you still have to make and
manufacture the sheet metal
with the handles,
only once though.
VIVIAN: So in our
experiment, we concluded
that our dugout was successful
in addressing the need
to reduce heat exposure.
It channels all the heat
down into the dugout
instead of at the
people working on it.
We also were able to decrease a
safety risk of the tip and kick
method.
Our sheet metal seals were also
successful in creating a seal
and resulting in a quality burn.
We did get some really good
carbonized material out
of this burn.
But there are definitely
still improvements to be made.
We can still work on the
maneuverability and handling
of these seals with the handles.
And we can also work on
adding a little more distance
between the person
and the barrel.
JESSICA: And so we're
at our next steps, which
are going to be to
send the documented
process of our new barrel
design or charcoal making design
to the women.
And they're going to make a
charcoal burn early next week.
We're going to phone call them
and talk to them directly,
I'll talk to them directly,
and get their feedback
on what the heat experience
was and see how they can--
explain that and whether
it's better or worse.
And finally, we're
going to continue
to look at improving
the sheet metal design
and seeing how we can
manufacture it easier,
or how we can just
get it a better design
so we can maneuver it better.
And finally, of course, we're
here to incorporate your input.
So questions?
Questions?
Yes, Benjamin.
AUDIENCE: Have been able to
talk to them about the three
different options of how to
seal the holes in terms of
would you rather make a
plate, or would you rather
[INAUDIBLE].
JESSICA: So no, the
answer is no, not about
those three specific designs.
But in our conversations
with Lindsay,
which is sort of their
project coordinator or--
VIVIAN: Our liaison.
JESSICA: Our liaison.
Our liaison the
community, she says
that-- she continues to
say that the heat of it
is the biggest exposure.
So rather than have them
do the test trials and all
the experimentation of like
which feels best or taking all
this data that
we've been taking,
we tried to get the
data first and then
submit our conclusive
recommendations to them.
And then that's what they're
going to do this week.
AUDIENCE: How are you actually
going to communicate to them?
Do you need to describe
the whole thing as well?
JESSICA: Yeah, right now, when
you train a community to make
a charcoal burn, there's a
nifty document with diagrams
that D-Lab has produced
that tells them
how to make the holes, or
how to set up the bricks,
and all the process.
And so we're going to do that.
They've already been
trained with that.
And they have that document, we
trained them over spring break.
And so we're just going to sort
of an addendum, an appendix
to what the new
process should be,
and how they should dig
the hole, and all that.
So they can do their
charcoal burn next week.
CURT: And we have all the
specifications for the hole
based on air flow, so that's--
VIVIAN: How wide the
channel should be.
CURT: Exactly, so we can
send them very, very exact--
AUDIENCE: So before with
the original document,
they were able to go through
it without any training?
JESSICA: No, we were there
to train them personally.
You can-- it's hard to
communicate just with
a document of step
by step instructions,
even though they're
really well drafted,
because they still
have questions on--
it's really about understanding
the why of things.
But now that they understand
the why of things,
like why it has to be
sealed at a certain time,
now it's a matter of just
saying, instead of mounting
the barrel on the bricks,
instead make a hole,
insert bricks, and
put the barrel on top.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
expectations [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: It seems like--
how do you-- if
you're going to plug
the hole with a third brick,
how do you get the brick there?
I mean that, does
that inevitably
involve your hand a half an
inch away from the barrel?
JESSICA: Sure, so you can make
other contraptions that we've
considered, like a reach,
the things that you
use to reach really far away and
just grab it and put it there.
But the simplest
design is that when--
I'll show you the
picture, when you
can walk right
next to the barrel,
you can stand right here.
And you're not feeling any heat.
So you can-- you just
drop in the brick.
You're technically not
feeling any heat over you.
Whereas, even with the
sheet metal design,
you're directly in front
of the channel that does
have the heat coming out of
it, if that makes any sense.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
surprised that you're
getting so heat in the
channel [INAUDIBLE]..
JESSICA: Comparatively--
CURT: I think a lot
of it is smoke, too.
A lot of smoke comes
out of the channels.
JESSICA: And comparatively,
remember that it
was all on bricks before.
So all the heat was
radiating out of the bottom.
And that was going right to
their feet, to their ankles,
and whatnot.
AUDIENCE: But there's-- if it's
just as easy for them to bring
nine bricks as six bricks, then
the easiest way to tell them
how wide the hole should be is
that it should be a brick wide.
Just measure it with the bricks
you're about to use to plug in.
But you can't get there
[INAUDIBLE] is not working.
CURT: So that's why
for the time being,
we still prefer a solution
with the metal plates.
PROFESSOR: So Jess, you
tested with a hot barrel
putting the bricks in?
Not with the hot barrel, no.
CURT: We time tested.
PROFESSOR: OK,
because I question
that you wouldn't be exposed
to heat but putting a brick in.
JESSICA: In our video,
I was significantly
close to the sheet metal.
And I had to be
over the channel.
So I can only imagine that
being on the side of it, where
the smoke isn't rising
would be better.
But that is actually
what we're going
to be testing on Monday, which
is we're going to have two--
we're going to do two barrels.
And we're going to be testing
the thermometer readings
along the different
points around the barrel
at different distances.
AUDIENCE: So are you
converging to one?
JESSICA: We're going to be
testing where it's hottest.
So if there is a really
significant difference
between right above the--
right above the
channel and here, then
we know that this is a
safer area or a better area
for them to work with.
AUDIENCE: How are you--
how would you test that?
JESSICA: There's a high
resolution thermometer
that we're borrowing from 2671.
And--
AUDIENCE: That's just one of
the infrared gun thermometers?
JESSICA: No, no it's
just ambient temperature.
AUDIENCE: Is that
maybe air temperature?
Temperature on skin or surface?
JESSICA: No, not on
skin or surface, just
like-- you can just hold
it, so air temperature,
ambient temperature.
I'm not sure.
I haven't looked at it.
But that's what the
description says.
There's a surface one that
depends on the surface, surface
roughness, and the surface
change of temperature,
too, right on the material.
But this one is just supposed
to be able to hold it up.
AUDIENCE: And if you
have something metallic
in the source, it's most
likely radiating to it.
You're not going to measure
any heat of that emissions
of the metals can be so
low for the absorbance
of the [INAUDIBLE] is going to
be so low so when you see you
smoke coming out of it, do you--
so smoke is coming out of the
channels at the bottom, right?
So is that happening
the entire time,
or only after you seal the top?
CURT: Only after
you seal the top.
AUDIENCE: Is there any reason
you can't seal the bottom
and then seal the top.
CURT: The top is just more of--
there's actually fire
coming out of it.
And if the wind changes
direction really quickly
and if you're standing
close to the barrel,
you could actually be
pretty close to the flame.
So the way it's--
the way the barrel is sealed
now is with the top first
and then kicking out
the bricks afterwards.
So we've just stuck with that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But you don't want this thing
going, wiggling back and forth
when the top is open, because
maybe some embers will
come flying out, or
something like that.
But if you're not wiggling
the barrel, maybe you
can just seal the bottom first
and smoke won't billowing out
of the bottom, and then
you can seal the top.
VIVIAN: I think because smoke
is still coming out at eye level
when the top is open.
So our intuition tells us to
seal the top first before we--
PROFESSOR: Well, maybe
that's another experiment.
VIVIAN: Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: And the point about
measuring heat is complicated.
And so you-- it's coming at
you in two different ways.
And your measurement
device is vital to measure
one or the other
of those ways, you
might want to try a
bunch of different ways.
I mean, it's-- because what
you're going to be getting is
radiant heat.
As bogus as this sounds,
you might actually
get a more useful
measurement by [INAUDIBLE]
either how hot does
it feel, or if you
want to get some kind of
integrated measurement,
you buy three
cantaloupes, because those
are at least look
like human beings
and will absorb radiated
heat about the same way.
If you put them around
the thing, and then
measure how hot they
get 15 minutes later.
Something, but you
need an absorber
that looks like a
person, [INAUDIBLE]
because the metal is going to
reflect all the radiating heat.
AUDIENCE: So another way to
do that is to just wrap half
or a third of the barrel
vertically in tinfoil
and use some of metallic
wire to strap in tin foil
to one third of barrel
or half the barrel.
And that will act as a
huge radiation shield.
So if you want to,
that would just
tell if the heat is coming from
hot air coming from the bottom
or from radiation
off the barrel.
And then you would know
actually what your problem is.
CURT: That would be a good test.
JESSICA: Any other comments,
especially on the sheet metal
seal and whatnot?
PROFESSOR: I just wouldn't
bank on the women being
able to do a test
early next week as part
of your critical path.
Sure.
JESSICA: Lindsey did already
say that they wanted to do
a burn, that's why we are
not counting on it, but--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
absolutely, but I
think you should try
to make that happen.
But also, if it takes them
a week to make it happen,
be able to work with that too.
AUDIENCE: One thing
I noticed when
you were showing the
video of you sliding
the covers on [INAUDIBLE].
It looked like it would
be helpful to have--
to have a way to pick up the
front edge with a simple stick.
So I think it should be--
[INAUDIBLE] by putting-- putting
another block in the back.
So you have another lever
point, push the stick in here,
and effectively pick
it up like that,
just slide it over the bricks,
because it [INAUDIBLE]..
That would be as far back
towards the back edge.
JESSICA: One of our
designs, actually,
after this experiment was
to make a pole insert, where
you can put in the wood.
But it was mostly for more--
PROFESSOR: And then
on the flip side,
trying to minimize
how much metal is used
is also important,
because it's expensive.
CURT: So in the design that
Jessica just referenced,
you tip your sheet.
And it would have to
be thinner than this.
And then you could
cut it in here,
and then there, and leave
a certain point there.
And just bend those two
edges together, and just
pull them once on top.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
but I also wonder
if the bricks are decently
sealed against the grass,
if you could make your devices
significantly smaller to just
cover the hole and
not the whole area.
AUDIENCE: Do you have to
get sand all the way around
the barrel?
CURT: Oh, yeah, yeah.
JESSICA: So I can't
forward to it.
PROFESSOR: If you
exit out a PowerPoint,
you might be able to load
it in QuickTime or whatever.
Yeah, so you don't want
to be rocking the barrel.
We don't-- like they did a
different order than we do
in the video.
So we normally just
put the lid on top.
But then we drop it down
before we put the sand,
so you don't have sand falling
off when you're rocking it.
So you don't-- that's why
I said they should try it.
Because you don't have to
put the lid on top first.
JESSICA: Just to show them?
CURT: The ceiling?
[? The ceiling? ?]
JESSICA: Yeah, he asked for what
the final thing looked like.
CURT: [INAUDIBLE]
JESSICA: And what happened
here was that the grass,
it was a lot fluffier
here than Nicaragua.
Over there, it's kind of
burnt out, kind of dry,
kind of just-- not
that much grass.
And so we know
that there won't be
that much air holes
through the grass that
will have to seal sand all
the way around excessively
like that.
Any other questions,
or thoughts, or--
AUDIENCE: How much
harder is [INAUDIBLE]??
CURT: We didn't
think it was really
a problem in our
experimentation.
But you can still have strands
of the biomass coming out
through the channels and then
just light them right there.
And in fact, it
may even be easier,
because there's no
wind passing through.
So it wasn't--
VIVIAN: It's probably
either the same
or easier than the
current method.
JESSICA: On Amelia's
clock, it was
14 seconds, which
is more or less what
it took us with other--
Great, thank you.
CURT: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JUAN DIAZ: So hello, everyone.
We're GrupoFenix.
Well, we're the other
part of Grupo Fenix.
We All traveled together,
but it's two projects.
I'm Juan.
AUDIENCE: I guess I would wait
until they're done [INAUDIBLE]..
LIZ DE REGT: We're
pretty awesome.
JUAN DIAZ: We have
electricity, too.
So I'm Juan.
LIZ DE REGT: I'm Liz.
SID PAL: I'm Sid.
And our--
JUAN DIAZ: Our mentors
are Amelia and Steve.
So I'll just start
with currently,
we're working with the
cooperative in [INAUDIBLE] that
makes the--
makes solar cells--
they make solar panels.
And they use it for
home power and also
for as individual
cellphone chargers.
Currently, these are the large
solar panels that they make.
They're 60 watts.
You can see each
solar cell is donated.
And all their solar cells
that are used are donated.
And they're about
500 cells per box--
LIZ DE REGT: Well, they do have
to be bought, but they're--
JUAN DIAZ: Oh, sorry,
they're bought,
but they're bought for a
lower price because they're--
LIZ DE REGT: Rejects.
JUAN DIAZ: They're rejects from
the factory here in the US.
The problem is that
they're really fragile,
and a lot of them break
on the shipping there.
And so right now,
they're also making--
sorry, right now, they're
also making solar cellphone
chargers.
But to make the solar
cellphone chargers,
they need to cut
each individual cell,
so they can get a
really high-- so they
can get a high enough
voltage, but still
have a small enough solar
panel that it's transportable.
Yeah, so there's just--
this is a landscape of
the place where we are.
You can see there is no
grid on a lot of the houses.
But a lot of people
still have cellphones.
And so some of them have to walk
up to two or three kilometers
to charge their cellphones.
And they pay 10 [INAUDIBLE],,
which is about $0.50 per
charge.
So that is where-- that is how
we want to help the project.
There's an example of a
Chinese made cellphone charger
that they have used.
As you can see, it charges, and
it comes with an extra battery
and it charges the extra
battery in that device.
But this only fits--
one, i only fits
Nokia cellphones.
And two, it's imported.
So this is-- we don't think
it's really helping the--
I guess the job
market in the area.
LIZ DE REGT: And it costs $20.
JUAN DIAZ: Oh, it
also costs $20.
So our goal is to make-- so
this is why, I guess, this
is why we want to make
a cellphone charger.
So we want to make one
that is can hopefully
compete with this, not
only initial manufacturing
costs, but at least in the end
cots to their own manufacturing
costs, can reduce their time.
Currently, it
takes them 24 hours
to make the small
cellphone chargers.
And it can also--
so time, and it can
also be transportable,
and charge their cellphones, and
charge all the different types
of cellphones that they have.
SID PAL: OK, so as Juan said,
basically, the solar cells
output 0.5 volts each.
And this is the original cell.
The way they do it right
now is that they cut up
these cells into four parts
across like that and then
connect them in series.
So you can step up your voltage.
Unfortunately, what
ends up happening
is when you're cutting these
cells, as Juan mentioned,
they're very fragile.
So you end up wasting
a lot of your cells.
And that, actually,
is the largest--
they spend the most
amount of their money
in cutting the cells and
then using the silicone.
But we'll get into that later.
So we decided that
it would be helpful
if they could just use
the original cells instead
of cutting them.
And so we thought that
if they just connected
three of these
cells in series, you
could go up to 1.5 volts, which
is about a normal pencil cell.
And then we thought
we would just
step up that voltage to 5 volts,
which is what a cell phone
charger uses.
To do that, we bought--
so this is the circuitry
that we're using.
So essentially, a lot of--
I mean, we couldn't
actually make the step up.
We tried, but we failed.
So we decided to just
buy it off the shelf.
And so this is how
our bread board looks.
Essentially, this would
be our input right here.
And this would be 1.5 DC input.
And then you'd have a 5 volt
DC output coming in from here.
And basically, your solar
cells would be connected.
So you're solar cells are here.
And this little thing fits in
to this depression right here.
And then so your panels
are connected in series.
You have two wires connecting
to these terminals.
It steps up to 5 volts and goes
out to connect to this thing.
This thing then goes into
your Nokia/whatever phone
you have and then
charges your phone.
Do you have the video?
LIZ DE REGT: Make sure
my volumes on, though.
JUAN DIAZ: So we
kind of made a video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- OK, so we're
switching on the light.
[INAUDIBLE] right here.
Now, we're going to
measure the voltage output
of our solar cells.
So 1.6 volts, that's good.
Now going to measure the
voltage output after we step up.
LIZ DE REGT: Can you
guys hear that at all?
- That's good.
Now Juan's going to
plug in the cellphone.
And it says charging.
0.8--
LIZ DE REGT: Which is the
voltage across the battery.
So it makes sense
that we're just
plugging in it's 0.8
volts instead of 0.5
[END PLAYBACK]
SID PAL: Yeah, so that's
basically the works like.
Yeah, I think
that's pretty much--
LIZ DE REGT: Yeah,
and then we've also
been talking to the community.
I'm hoping we can talk to
them on the phone soon.
This week, they haven't
really been in contact,
because it's Holy Week.
But we sent them this in Spanish
and some other instructions
about what we've
been working on.
So we kind of hope to
get their feedback.
This is our-- kind of looks
like model you saw tested,
kind of can put this stuff
into this indentation here.
So that when it's not in
use, or when it's noon,
it can be completely flat.
This also protects all of
the circuitry from the rain
and that kind of thing.
There could be notches
added to the side.
So that for instance, you could
make it lower by lowering these
and it could be like
that and stay still.
And it's also just something
they can really simply make.
They also make other things
with wood in the same center.
So they have all the materials.
It's pretty low cost.
And you can add--
WE have a hole
here for security,
you could see in the picture.
So that if they want to
tie it up and lock it
to something while it's
charging, they can do that.
It's pretty portable, but
it's also not so small
that's going to just
stick it in their pocket
and run away with it.
It's adjustable.
And just easy for them to make.
So we're hoping
that they like it.
They can easily change the
looks like design as well.
Most of how we're
trying to help them
is actually, because they're
pretty capable of coming up
with things like
this themselves,
but this is just
kind of a suggestion.
We've also been talking
with some other people who
are working on the other
aspects of the solar panels,
like trying to make
the application
of the glass on top easier
and things like that.
So other people have
that part covered.
So we're focusing a lot on
just making it actually able
to charge a cell phone.
And what we're looking
to do next is right now,
it's on the breadboard.
And it's-- definitely if you
handed this to a customer,
and we're like don't break it,
something's going to come out.
And then they won't
know what to do with it.
So we have to make it more
able to be actually given
to somebody and not break,
so more durable, I guess.
We need to be able to
make it easy to explain.
Because we might not
have anybody down there
showing them, they can
still learn how to do it.
They have a mechanic--
I mean, an engineer
who's been trained
and should know how to put
this together reasonably well.
And he's definitely better
at soldering than we are.
So it should be doable.
Thank you.
SID PAL: And I'd like to be
clear, this is just a model.
This is actually going
to be a solar panel.
This is not wood, in case
people were kind of confused.
This is the solar panel.
But since our project focuses
on converting the voltage
to a cell phone
charging voltage,
we decided to just like go
with this just to show you guys
how it's going to look
when the solar panel is,
in fact, installed.
Yeah, that's pretty much it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SID PAL: Three, three.
SID PAL: Yeah, pretty much.
AUDIENCE: What's the
cost of your circuitry?
SID PAL: So we
estimate-- so right now,
we bought five of each.
If you buy them large
scale, sorry, wholesale,
I think this--
I think this thing should
cost about $4, this entire--
LIZ DE REGT: This
cost us like $6.
SID PAL: This was
about $6 for us,
but I think it should cost $4.
And then so the connectors
are actually more expensive,
but that's because--
so there are two ways to do it.
Either you buy the
whole thing, cut it off,
but that doesn't make
any sense, right?
So I look-- when we looked it
up online, you can buy about 10
of them for $7, but
there are probably
cheaper ways to buy them.
Maybe if we contacted the
company, asked them about it.
We're still deciding how
to get them for cheap.
But we can definitely--
I think this should be about
$1 max, if you just buy it.
LIZ DE REGT: And then
when you add in their
the time they'll use.
It probably will take them
about eight hours now,
because they won't
have to cut cells.
So that'll eat out
another $4 or something,
because they're getting paid
about $0.50 an hour, I think.
So it'll definitely be able to
compete with the current one no
problem.
SID PAL: Anything--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUAN DIAZ: I'm sorry.
SID PAL: I'm sorry,
I didn't catch that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SID PAL: So basically
the concept--
the reason we decided to put
it in the depression underneath
was that if it did
rain, it wouldn't
be immediately affected.
That being said,
this isn't going
to protect it against-- if you
like leave it out in the rain,
it's not going to be protected.
So I guess the concept
is that you leave
it out only when it's bright.
But if it suddenly
starts to rain,
it'll give you a certain
amount of protection against it
before you can take it back in.
LIZ DE REGT: And the solar
cells themselves, to be clear,
are not going to be just like--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SID PAL: Just a panel.
LIZ DE REGT: They'll still do
the process with a silicone
glass on top, because
that's necessary.
You can't-- I mean, the
cells get damaged if you
don't encapsulate them.
SID PAL: I mean,
just to be clear,
I realized we didn't
explain how the panel looks.
The way the panel
looks is that you
have the three solar cells
in series, which are then
encapsulated in silicone.
You have an aluminum frame.
So you have an aluminum frame,
you have these cells in series.
And they're encapsulated
by silicone.
You then pressure--
you put pressure
on a glass frame on top
of it and leave it sit.
And then you have a
plastic sheet underneath.
So this is basically waterproof.
And this is what we're
talking about will be here.
LIZ DE REGT: Because these
are the kinds of panels
that they stick on their
roofs and they use for power.
SID PAL: Except
in our case, you'd
have only three
cells as opposed to--
LIZ DE REGT: Yeah, so
it's a lot less time.
A lot of the problems
with the big ones
is when you encapsulate
it, you have
to push it down and make sure
that there's no air bubbles.
And it's really
hard on a big panel
to make sure there's no bubbles.
But on the smaller ones,
it's mostly the cutting
that they said they
really need to get rid of.
So that's what our goal was.
SID PAL: And the goal,
basically, like Liz said,
is to eliminate
cutting the cells.
Because that's a pain.
LIZ DE REGT: It's a
pain, and they break--
they said, if they
have five cells,
they'll break three of them.
So they won't break these,
because they're just
full cells.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
asked this question,
but have you tried, in
lab, pointing that halogen
light at the solar
cell and actually
fully charging the phone?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: The efficiency
on that is so horrifying.
Has to be, I mean,
it's like 0.1%,
I mean, it's like 10
amps, 15 amps at 120 volts
to get a milliwat in the
phone, which is crazy.
But you should try it.
SID PAL: Yeah, we actually got--
the video we showed
you was yesterday.
So we're probably going to
try that over the weekend.
AUDIENCE: You
should just set it--
I mean, find a phone
that will actually
give you some kind of decent
readout of how charged it is.
And run it for half
an hour and see
how much the charge
increases over half an hour,
or take out the battery,
measure the voltage on the cell
at a couple of different
times or something.
LIZ DE REGT: We did a
rough calculation based on.
It should have about
100 milliamp current
and how long that should take.
And it'll be longer
than the China one.
The China one was
about five hours.
And this, hopefully, will be
like seven or eight hours,
but we have not tested this.
So that could be a big problem
we have to figure that out.
AUDIENCE: You may just find that
you need to have the storage.
There's not enough-- if there's
not enough current coming out
of that thing to
charge in real time,
you may have to add
a battery to that,
so you can store a little
bit of that charge.
[INAUDIBLE]
JUAN DIAZ: We have
also been testing
the voltage
necessary to actually
get enough voltage to--
so we can get enough
voltage that it
can be stepped up to 5 volts.
And right now, we're
getting that is
1.2 volts is the minimum.
According to the circuit,
we should be able--
we should be able to step up to
5 volts using only 0.7 volts.
So we're going to
keep trying that.
LIZ DE REGT: But it also
shouldn't be much of a problem,
because in Nicaraguan sun,
it is a volt and a half.
It would have to be
like sunset for it
to be that low if he's
charging our solar cellphone
at that hour of the day.
SID PAL: Yeah, but I mean,
yeah, so we're definitely
going to try that though just
try and charge the cellphone.
Part of our initial
plan was actually
to have a separate energy
storage device in our system.
But we decided that
would increase costs.
And so we thought that if
we could do it without that,
But yeah that's always
a possibility, though.
PROFESSOR: Feedback from
Mauro or others a GrupoFenix?
LIZ DE REGT: Yeah, we
really need to talk to them.
They're not very good
at getting back to us.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
I would encourage
you to use the phone next week.
LIZ DE REGT: Yeah,
we want to talk.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
We have a lot of questions,
that a conversation
will be really helpful.
AUDIENCE: So how
do non-Nokia phones
did you see when you were there?
LIZ DE REGT: We only actually
saw two kinds of cell phones,
we saw Nokia and ZTE phone.
The ZTE phone can be
charged in similar way.
It's the same voltage, but
it's a different connector.
We could also do this
with a USB charger,
but the Nokia phone
can't be charged via USB.
So we just used that--
we're waiting--
Lindsay, the woman,
who is the liaison that the
other group was talking about,
said that she has a spreadsheet
with what kind of cell phones
everyone has.
We're trying to get that her.
But we asked a lot of people,
and those are the only two
cellphones we saw.
SID PAL: So right now, these
are the two connectors we have.
This one charges the Nokia.
And then this one's
a USB charger.
So any more questions?
OK, well, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1:
As we speak, we're
actually going to pass
around the little Ziploc bags
of the experiments
we did with the rice.
And the NGO that we worked
with was called ASAPROSAR.
And we are actually
part of the class
that went to El Salvador
and not Nicaragua.
We worked in a community called
La Magdalena in El Salvador.
And the NGO is currently
introducing rice cultivation
in the community both to be
used as a source of income
and also as nutrition.
And in order for the rice
to be ready for consumption,
it needs to be processed.
And the process involves
threshing and dehusking.
And current methods of dehusking
are very time and money
intensive.
They usually involve
a two to three
hour bus ride to a mill where
the rice can be processed.
And it costs about $3
to $4, we found out,
which is about a daily salary.
So our design challenge is
to develop a method that's--
for more local, faster, and
cheaper way of dehusking rice.
The two most important
project specifications
that we focused on
were the efficiency,
which refers to
the amount of rice
that's successfully
dehusked, and also
how gentle the
process is, meaning
we wanted to minimize the amount
of rice that's broken or cut
in half.
And some of the other
specifications we looked at
were safety, affordability, of
course, durability, and also
aesthetics.
We approached the
problem by brainstorming.
We researched some
existing technologies
that people use in regions
that rice is grown.
Some of them are more simple.
Some of them involve
heavy machinery.
What we concluded, though, is
that all of these technologies
use friction in order to
get the husk from the rice.
And it's a matter of adjusting
the amount of friction
we have in order to get the
husk off, but not break the rice
grain.
And some of the
ideas we ran through
were pepper grinder, where
we have cylinders rotating
together, rubbing
together plates
that can be made from different
materials, mortar and pestle
idea which is used, but it's
a lot more energy intensive
and not as efficient, and
also the molino, which
is a corn mill that's
currently used in El Salvador
to grain corn.
And that's basically
two circular plates
that rub together.
And that's what we
actually have over there.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So
Amy Smith actually
had visited this
community before we had.
And she had looked
at this molino
and inserted a black inner tube
in between the two metal parts.
So we use that kind of
as our standard when
we were looking
at how we could go
about improving this process.
So we used this Pugh chart
with these attributes
to figure out which one would
be the most feasible to do this
semester and which one
would be the most efficient
for the community
to use overall.
In the end, we chose to
modify the existing molino
by inserting a different
material in between the plates.
Right now, we have the two
leather inserts in there.
So we kind of just
add a circular insert
in between them.
The advantages of
using the molino
is that our community
partner, ASAPROSAR is actually
distributing the molinos to
the community to use for corn--
to make cornmeal,
to grind yucca, to--
and so it's very
multifunctional for them.
And although the cost
is $20, ASAPROSAR
is funding this distribution
to the communities.
And as it is now, either
one family will use it,
or a whole community
will use it.
So it's available
to a lot of people.
It's pretty durable.
The metal is pretty rigid.
And it's not labor intensive.
It's just a hand
crank that you use.
A few of the challenges
with the molino,
though, is that when you just
do it without any insert,
it cracks or breaks the rice.
So people don't really
necessarily want broken rice.
And it wears the material down.
If you put something
in there, we kind of
need a durable material that
will withstand this turning.
So we decided upon five
different materials
that we wanted to test.
And we looked at leather,
rubber, metal, wood,
and fabric.
And based on those, we looked at
the cost, residue, durability,
and availability of those.
We brought back leather and
rubber from El Salvador,
so we actually could
use stuff that was
available in those communities.
And Lucy will talk to
you about what we found.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: So we did
quite a few experiments
where the main variables
that we were really testing
were what type of material
that we wanted to use,
and then also how many
turns of the molino
that we were going to do.
So first, to just highlight the
main steps of the experiments
that we did, first, we
inserted the material.
And then in order to be
able to accurately measure
how much space there
actually existed
in between the sides of
the molino and the insert,
we tightened it
as far as we could
once we inserted the material.
And then we measured it from
the number of turns out,
so how much we
actually loosened it
from the most tight position.
And then we use the
same amount of rice
for each experiment, 50 grams.
And we ran it through, and once
it had gone through the molino,
we sifted it through to get rid
of the really crushed pieces.
And then we winnowed
it, so essentially just
tossing the rice up, so the air
will catch and blow the husks
away.
So you can get rid of the husks.
And then we separated the
rice into four main components
being the rice that
was still husked,
the rice that was
whole, the rice that
was crushed or broken,
and then also if there
were any husks left as well.
And then we noted--
and you'll see the
bags themselves
are labeled, as they're
going passing around,
how many turns that it
took and then the number--
the weight of the
still husked rice,
husked rice, and if it
was in pieces and such.
So this is a--
I like this picture--
is a picture of the rice
that has-- is still husked,
a whole grain of dehusked
rice, a broken grain, and then
some of the
particles that we use
to sift through to get rid of.
And so one of the experiments
we use with the honeycomb rubber
is what we called it--
the picture is kind
of self-explanatory
why we called it that.
But so we did a couple
of experiments with this.
And you can see in the pictures
that we have, whether the--
it's kind of hard to
see from these pictures,
but once we've separated it
through how much of the rice
is still husked,
how much of the rice
has been dehusked based
on the number of turns.
What we noted about
the rubber, though,
is that we weren't very sure
how hazardous the residue that
might end up on
the rice would be,
because it's not an
organic material.
We also noted that this rubber
cost about $6 per square foot.
So it's not too inexpensive.
Another, we decide to
flip that rubber around
and decided to test it with
the different textures.
And the same thing
happens with this rubber.
Again, it's not organic.
So we did a quick
little data sheet
based on the number of turns
and the mass we started with,
and then the mass
that was broken,
and just to get an idea.
Then we continued on with
leather, which was the kind--
since it's organic and
a little bit cheaper
than the rubber, made us
feel a little bit better,
it's the one we
kind of preferred.
And it's very readily tested.
But we were trying to decide
how many layers of the leather
we should put.
All right, so as we did the
experiments with a leather,
sometimes we processed
it through twice.
Sometimes we did
different number of turns
with different layers.
And you can see, most of
them are relatively the same,
some were a little bit better.
But ultimately, we decided--
well, we decided that the
material wasn't the biggest
part.
But we still decided to
test with duct tape, which
we found, unfortunately,
wore away relatively quickly.
And then we tried for the
heavyweight of a flat sheet
metal surface.
And essentially,
that was a disaster.
So I'll hand it over to Benji.
GUEST SPEAKER 4: So
one of the reasons
that we decided to go
against the flat metal
was because the rice
wasn't actually fed
into the molino the
way that the plate,
the way that the backplate
is designed and shape it
feeds in the rice.
And so we decided to just
focus on the one side,
on the back side of
the molino and just
adding the material there.
So as you can see, we
have a lot of the tests.
And we did a lot of
tests, but actually, there
was no conclusive
awesome material
that was way better at husking
the rice than the others.
And so basically we
said, OK, well we
noticed that the most important
variable for deciding that
was the number of turns
away from tightening it.
And so we said, well, we still
have to decide on a material.
So we wanted to optimize
how much rice is broken,
and also just think about the
robustness and the availability
of the material.
And so we decided
on choosing leather,
because of the
availability and because
of-- because it is
organic, it's much safer.
And so going, we did a couple
of more exploratory tests
with the leather and trying
to decide how soft we wanted
to make the leather,
effectively,
like how it interacts
with the rice.
And so we tried with two pieces
of leather glued together
and then three pieces together.
And unsurprisingly, we
actually found that they
were very similar as well.
So we decided on going
with two pieces of leather
rather than the three, because
it's just less material,
it's less expensive.
And so going
forward, we're going
to be optimizing that
two layer process.
Or how we're going to be
gluing those together,
what type of glue,
or if we're going
to sew them together,
because the glue might not
be available.
And so we'll be looking at
those details of that leather
material.
But also, we wanted to look at
the process of how it's being--
how it's being put
through the mill,
so not only changing
the material,
but also thinking, well, if we
change the number of turns to,
say, three times
more than usual.
And then going through it twice,
does that change the results?
Is it more gentle
with the rice if you
process through it twice while
husking more of the material.
So we'll be looking at that,
or if we can do anything
to the rice prior to
actually running it
through the molino that
would make it more effective
for dehusking it.
So that's about it.
If you guys have
any questions, we
can also show how this
is working so far.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: One reason
was for explaining it
to community partners.
It's a lot easier to
say [INAUDIBLE] tight
as you can tighten it
as opposed to three
millimeters in
between, because you
don't want to use exact
measurements like that.
And also kind of gave us--
using different materials
gave us a lot of flexibility
with [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So this is the
you're talking about.
So let's see I let you know
GUEST SPEAKER 1: And then
how many turns do you do?
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Three.
GUEST SPEAKER 1:
One, two, three.
GUEST SPEAKER 4: We could do
a little more, so it's easier.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: And it
takes a little bit of--
the first few turns and
the last few hours are--
but it takes a while
for it to start,
because it just needs some
amount of rice to be--
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So we have--
a little bit of--
there's a lot of broken pieces.
So with this setup, we found
that four, or five, or six
turns, just because we
found that having the rice
not actually be
husked, we'd rather
have rice that's not
dehusked as opposed
to a lot of broken pieces.
GUEST SPEAKER 4: I'm not
sure if you guys also saw
the bag that was just broken.
So basically, it still husks.
It still husks
[INAUDIBLE] material,
but it's actually much
more effective than just--
AUDIENCE: Where's
the leather from?
GUEST SPEAKER 4: From a shoe?
AUDIENCE: Do you know
how they made it?
This is leather tanning,
I mean, that leather
could be the most toxic
thing you have, conceivably.
I mean, one of the things that
is used in leather tanning
is chromium sulfate
as the tanning agent.
So like it's just
worth finding out.
I mean, another
option is tannin,
which comes from oak trees.
Guessing not a lot of oak tress
in El Salvador, but, yeah,
it's worth finding out.
Because it would be sad
to poison everybody.
It's hard to get invited
back after-- well,
they can't invite you
back if they're all dead.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Also,
we've been waiting for them
to respond to questions.
But some of the
questions that we've
been trying to get answers
to are how many people
may need the--
how many people can
use it, would it
be a family or whole community?
And how much rice
do they consume?
How much rice can they grow?
And I think that's going-- it's
going to be important for us
to in terms of the material and
how durable the material is.
And is it-- does each family
have a piece of this leather,
or is it permanently
attached to the molino.
Or so there's a lot of
questions that we're still--
AUDIENCE: I just wouldn't
take for granted what
is and isn't toxic based on.
Because the rubber could be
fine for all that we know.
And the leather
could be poisonous.
And if what comes off is
stuff that you can wash off,
then it's not--
GUEST SPEAKER 2:
Well, the problem
is the inner tube was
that it was leaving
like a black residue on there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, if
it's like marking
like a crayon on each one, yeah.
But if there's a little
bit of rubber dust
that comes off, but is
not adhering to anything,
you can wash it off--
AUDIENCE: Your
[? Yellow ?] [? River. ?]
AUDIENCE: So it's just
worth actually finding out
what chemicals are
actually present,
because it might be that you
could eat a loaf of that rubber
and you be fine.
But if you chew on the
leather for a little bit.
GUEST SPEAKER 4: It's
just hard to control
that, you know what I mean?
The shops will be
doing [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Well, I think
it's worth figuring out.
Worst case scenario,
this leather
is tanned with whatever
chemical Steve just mentioned.
Is that something that's
going to get absorbed
into the rice or something
that's going to be washed off
during processing.
If it's going to get
absorbed, maybe we
need to knock this
leather out as a contender
to find something similar.
Because it seemed like
different materials
all seem to work
basically the same.
And so would an old t-shirt
work just as well or something,
I don't?
AUDIENCE: How did fabric work?
GUEST SPEAKER 4: Yeah,
so that's the reason
we did duct tape was
not as an actual design,
but just to see
how long it lasts,
because it is like
generally wear resistant.
GUEST SPEAKER 1:
But it does wear.
And we tried this foam material.
And that-- you can see that--
GUEST SPEAKER 4:
With even running
this much of the 50
grams with the duct tape,
you could tell it was worn.
And actually do tests
between denim and leather
for motorcycles.
And they'd simulate
someone falling down,
and the leather lasts
for 90 feet of dragging
while denim lasts for five.
And denim is like very durable.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: I don't
if Benji showed you
about the inside of these.
Can you--
AUDIENCE: It was like
trying to grind sandpaper.
It's going to wreck
whatever you put into it.
GUEST SPEAKER 2:
Both sides are rich.
AUDIENCE: There's a reason
why those things are made out
of metal.
GUEST SPEAKER 4:
So that's how we're
looking at doing flat metal,
so that was more durable.
But like I mentioned, we need
the design on the inner part
to pull the right through.
Otherwise, the
material [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: I mean, even if you
make the inner hole, the metal
piece that goes
on this side, did
you make the inner hole big
enough so that the rice could
come out?
GUEST SPEAKER 4: Yeah,
so it needs the like--
this cutting in the
other dimension,
it can't actually just be
a flat surface, no matter
how big the hole is,
because the rice isn't
allowed to feed into it.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: These will
just wear the material down.
It's on both size.
AUDIENCE: Have you found--
I didn't go look, I was too busy
looking up how you tan leather
while you were
talking about that.
But there are--
all over YouTube,
there are videos of how
manufacturing processes happen,
usually put up by the people
who built the equipment.
And I'd be curious how they
actually-- how rice actually
processed.
GUEST SPEAKER 4:
Yes, they do it--
they do it with like rollers,
basically, like rubber rollers
a lot of times, which is-- it's
a totally different geometry
than the molino.
But like we said,
it's the friction.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
just wonder if there's
pieces of that you can steal.
If that's too coarse, but a flat
plate with a single slot cut in
would get would you--
if you had grooves
cut in it that
happened to be about the
right size for a grain of rice
or something.
[INAUDIBLE] I don't know.
I'm just wondering
if there are tricks.
PROFESSOR: This
might be too far out,
but what about a
tumbling process instead
of a grinding process?
GUEST SPEAKER 4: Yeah,
the [INAUDIBLE]----
there's a team also doing
[INAUDIBLE] in the D-Lab
design, I believe.
But [INAUDIBLE] is
actually very soft.
And it doesn't end up getting
damaged by the tumblers.
Whereas the husks are
actually pretty soft
and the rice is hard.
So if there were tumblers,
just from looking at it,
the rice would probably
get more crushed,
whereas the husks probably
wouldn't really as much.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: We found the
soft materials really give
and allow the husks to
come off with the friction,
but not damage the rice as much.
[INAUDIBLE] or softer as
opposed to kind of that.
AUDIENCE: What's wrong
with broken rice?
GUEST SPEAKER 3: That's
something that we actually--
that we wanted to
ask the community.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: It
kind of gets mushy.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Well,
part of the reason
they want to use this as a
tool in their community is they
want to sell rice, too.
I assume, we haven't been in
contact with our community,
they haven't gotten back to us.
But we would assume that
they'd want to sell the grains.
PROFESSOR: One question, I
think I mentioned the last time
[INAUDIBLE] I want to ask is
what their expectations are
for broken rice if they
are any, from the mill,
if they get 20% broken rice
already and they just--
so I would get on the
phone the next week
and hopefully reach them.
Whatever material
you end up with,
whether it's leather or
something else, figuring out
just how long it does last, so
how many grams you can process
before you need to replace it
and then getting like a both
for your users,
so that they know
you should be reprocessing,
replacing it this often.
And also so you can get a cost
estimate for we're going to--
in a year, this
many tons of rice,
we're going to need this
much leather or whatever
it is could be useful.
AUDIENCE: Did you bring the
rice back from El Salvador?
Or is it from a farm nearby?
GUEST SPEAKER 4: It is
from a farm in Texas.
I mean, from comparison--
AUDIENCE: Nobody's going to let
you bring a sack of unhusked
rice from El Salvador.
If you did, you had it
hidden in a balled up sock.
PROFESSOR: All right,
thanks, you guys.